do you remember where you were on the
30th of november 2020
probably not i'd imagine but that date
sticks in my mind because i got a text
from a friend and colleague geneticist
adam rutherford it read have you seen
the news the protein folding problem
exclamation mark
wow i thought they've only gone and done
it
[Music]
in season one of this podcast i told the
story of how the ai company deepmind was
using artificial intelligence to take on
a 50 year old grand challenge in biology
now only a year later deepmind had
unveiled an ai system called alpha fold
that virtually solved the problem of
predicting the 3d shapes of proteins
the scientific world was full of
excitement a headline in the journal
nature declared this will change
everything
the president of the uk's royal society
called it a stunning advance that had
come decades before many in the field
would ever have predicted
and forbes dubbed it the most important
achievement in ai ever
[Music]
i'm professor hannah fry
i'm a mathematician and i have been
following the developments in artificial
intelligence for as long as i can
remember
in season two of deepmind the podcast
i've gone back inside the lab to speak
to countless researchers scientists and
engineers about their work
and i must say
i've seen some pretty extraordinary
things
from robots that have taught themselves
to walk around
looks like it's a drunk robot
to ais that can predict the weather it
is important to know if there's going to
be a buildup of a catastrophic storm and
generate human sounding voices
but it seemed only right to kick off the
first episode with what is probably
deepmind's biggest breakthrough so far
coming up we are gonna hear the full
story of alpha fault from the people who
were in the room where it happened
i remember sitting on the plane on the
way home writing out well what are all
the ideas that might actually work and
just sitting there going this is amazing
and this is terrifying
we'll find out how alpha fold could
rapidly accelerate the drug discovery
process we got hundreds and hundreds of
emails from excited biologists wanting
to try out their system
and paved the way for new discoveries
i think it's woken up the scientific
world to the possibility of what ai
could do
this is episode one a breakthrough
unfolds
one of those scientists who is paying
particular attention to the alpha fold
news is john mcgeehan professor of
structural biology at portsmouth
university
the first time i saw the story about
alpha fold i thought that can't be true
because it's about two decades too early
so i immediately started checking the
details of this to make sure i was
understanding it correctly i literally
emailed deepmind and said we could
really use this technology
to see how much of a game changer john
and the scientific world thinks the
alpha fold breakthrough might be
i want you to come with me on a trip to
the bottom of the ocean
every year somewhere between 8 to 12
million metric tons of plastic waste
gets dumped into the oceans and john has
made it his scientific mission to do
something about it
[Music]
some of that plastic is used once
sometimes just for minutes in the case
of maybe a fizzy drinks bottle
and if that enters the ocean some
plastics last hundreds of years in that
sort of environment what tends to happen
is through sunlight and waves
they break down but only into smaller
and smaller pieces and they end up being
microplastics
wildlife consumed this plastic it ends
up in our food chain and i think we're
only just starting to understand the
potential impact
there might just be a twinkling ray of
hope on the horizon
in march 2016 a japanese research group
announced in the journal science that
they discovered a species of bacteria
that could break the molecular bonds of
one of the world's most used plastics
polyethylene terephthalate
also known as p-e-t or polyester
p-e-t is found in products from fizzy
drink bottles to textiles
john's collaborator in the u.s greg
beckham instantly spotted the potential
of this discovery and gave him a call
and he said this japanese group has
literally found a bacterium living in a
plastic waste dump that is digesting
plastic it's actually using the plastic
as a food source
we had to figure out how these enzymes
worked and if we could make them faster
because the potential here is if you can
break down plastic into its building
blocks then suddenly you can recycle it
infinitely
we'll find out exactly how john mcginn
and his team are using alpha fold to
help fight plastic pollution a bit later
on
but for now because alpha fold predicts
the 3d structures of proteins it's
helpful to find out a bit more about how
proteins work in the human body we'll
make it lots of fun i promise because
proteins are truly fascinating things
proteins are these incredibly small
machines that are extraordinarily
unusual for the way that we think of
machines but they do the kind of
mechanical and chemical things that the
cell needs to
let me introduce you to john jumper who
leads the alpha fold project
the human cell has about 20 000 of these
nano machines and people make entire
careers explaining the function of one
of these proteins
proteins are the workforce behind
practically everything that happens
within the human body
you'll find them in our immune system
antibodies are a type of protein we
release that can fight bacteria and
viruses
the protein insulin is what allows our
bodies to absorb glucose
proteins even work to shepherd other
molecules around the body as in the case
of one particularly famous protein
hemoglobin is a protein whose job it is
to carry oxygen within your red blood
cells
your lungs are extracting that from the
air but then it needs to be carried
throughout the body and so it is
attached to this hemoglobin protein
which later releases it where it's
needed
and yet these powerful naturally
occurring machines are made from only a
small list of building blocks all the
machines that we have in kind of the
normal natural world
are
really really complex and the proteins
they have this lovely kind of modular
system where
there's 20 types of amino acids and a
protein in its simplest form is just a
line of these amino acids
these 20 amino acids tiny molecules made
up of a handful of atoms are the
building blocks of all human proteins
to make a protein these amino acids are
strung together in a sort of miniature
cellular factory called the ribosome
how about an analogy like one of those
bracelet kits my daughter has one right
and she wants to spell her name sarah so
she grabs the s and she puts it on the
line she grabs the a she puts it on the
line she'll surely grab a heart and put
it on the line
in the same sort of way you have beads
in a line or these amino acids that are
attached one at a time and when it's
done the protein leaves the ribosome
within milliseconds the forces of
physics gently tease the line of amino
acids into intricate 3d shapes which
give function to the protein and allows
them to work as miniature machines
you can think of it like origami a blank
piece of paper might hold all manner of
potential but it only becomes meaningful
once it's folded into shape
the 1d shape the line isn't so good at
telling us how these machines work how
we can build new ones
they really need to assemble into this
intricate 3d shape that we can start to
reason about
seeing a structure is really the
beginning
of explaining
why the protein is that way how it
misfunctions how we might be able to
develop drugs but it's extraordinarily
difficult to get this kind of
information
[Music]
most drugs work by binding to a
particular protein in a specific way
beta blockers stop the protein receptors
from noticing the adrenaline floating
past antibiotics work by interfering
with a bacteria's protein
this is partly why understanding the
shape of a folded protein is so
important
so what do folded proteins look like
well
these things are
tiny it's not like you could just look
at them down a microscope to see what
shape they are
at that scale they might as well be
invisible
to work out the structure you normally
have to use something called x-ray
crystallography
first of all you have to express your
protein so you need to coax a bacterium
into producing enough of it for your
experiments
here's catherine tunis awanagan a senior
research scientist then you have to be
able to get it out of the cell in
sufficient quantities then you need to
get it to form crystals which is often
the most difficult part and when you say
the most difficult part yeah are we
talking weeks it's very variable so if
you happen to be working with a protein
that's really well studied it can be a
very quick process if it's something
that's never been crystallized before it
can take years so i've had emails from
people who said you know we've worked on
this for 10 years we can't even make
enough of the stuff to start our
experiments that's an extreme case but
it can be as bad as that
[Music]
for the last 50 years numerous
scientists have dedicated their entire
working lives to painstakingly
uncovering the intricate structure of
proteins one at a time
slowly and surely building a collective
body of knowledge
but finding a shortcut getting from the
string of amino acids straight to the
folded protein has long been considered
one of the grandest challenges in
biology
[Music]
at some point in those intervening
decades in a pub in cambridge
denis asabus the man who would go on to
co-found deep mind first heard about the
protein folding problem
as an undergrad one of my friends was
obsessed with this problem and we used
to go to the pub and almost any
situation he would crowbar in the idea
of like if we solve protein folding that
would unlock all the biology
back in those days no one had quite
managed to get computers to reliably
predict how a general protein might fold
you could do it for tiny proteins where
the physics equations were tractable but
any larger and there were too many
variables
but that didn't put demis off from
wanting to have a go
there was this game called foldit people
were playing a game to fold proteins
and making some progress they were not
trained biologists they were gamers they
were able to find two or three protein
structures that were actually published
in nature they were actually quite big
breakthroughs so then finally when we
did alphago i thought well if we're able
to mimic the intruder process of a go
player then why couldn't we do what
these folded players were doing for
folding proteins
in 2016 before the team had even caught
the flight home after alphago's victory
demis was already eyeing up the next big
challenge for ai to work on protein
folding i'm sure we can do that his
conversation with alphago's lead
researcher david silva was captured by a
film crew that followed them down a
street in seoul where the match had
taken place it's just amazing seeing how
quickly a problem that is seen as being
impossible and changed to being
continuously done we consult protein
folding
there were good reasons for thinking
that an ai approach might work
it's a very interesting problem in the
sense that it has a very large search
space
push me kohli leads deepmind's science
team
the space of possible structures is just
infinite and yet it has definite
patterns hiding within
one of the things that makes this
problem great is the process is
extremely repeatable and specific the
sequence makes the structure but it's
also so complex that we don't know how
to write it down specifically
but we know how to write down a machine
that if you show it enough data we'll
learn these
something else that made protein folding
suitable for ai was the decades of work
by experimental biologists to find the
structures of proteins one by one
it meant an ai could peak at the back of
the textbook to learn how the patterns
worked
and much like in the game of go protein
faulting came with a ready-made way to
measure how well the algorithm was
performing
for nearly three decades there has been
a regular global competition amongst
biologists who use computers to fold
proteins
it's called the critical assessment of
protein structure prediction or casp
the way it works is you take a set of
100 proteins where you're challenged to
say i've got the sequence what does the
structure look like professor john molt
co-founded the casp competition in 1994
and to all work on those hundred in
parallel as a community and now you can
compare results
the accuracy of a protein fold
prediction in casp is measured using the
global distance test or gdt
you take a visual sketch of the true
folded protein and then superimpose the
calculated competition entries on top of
it
the more amino acids that end up roughly
where they should be the higher the
score
it's on a scale of 0 to 100 where 100
would be exact agreement with the
experimental structure so if you get to
something like 90 then you're arguing
with the experimentalists whether your
model is better than his structure
deepmind set up a new team with the task
of building an ai model that could
predict how a protein will fold from its
amino acid sequence it was led by john
jumper
how far away did you think success was
at the very beginning i wouldn't say
that we were sure of success there was
always this feeling that it's complex
but there's no rule that it can't be
understood but i would say it was
absolutely unclear that we were going to
be able to build it
i have always been one of the skeptics
on the team i sort of expected maybe 15
years from now we would have a system
like this and also i think in biology
there is quite a bit of skepticism often
about computational methods we think of
experiment as being the last word and it
can be an uphill struggle to convince a
biologist that a computational method is
really going to help them
the first version of alpha fold is the
one we talked about in season one of
this podcast
the team repurposed an ai technique
normally used for image analysis so that
it could work out which beads or amino
acids should be positioned close to each
other in the final protein
then the model crunched through the
different structures that could possibly
fit
it seemed to work pretty well although
it was slow and it took a lot of
computational power
in april 2018 deepmind entered alphafold
into the cast competition for the first
time
before the results were released one
member of team alpha fold tried to
predict how well they had done
he had run the numbers and by his
results we were 20th it was a one of the
more depressing moments of my career
finding out that after all this effort
we weren't even close to the top we had
a meeting where we very seriously saying
okay are we going to solve this problem
or should we be doing something else
that we can solve well give up was that
really on the table that was absolutely
i would say as a scientist my job is to
find a place to be useful you're always
saying do i want to spend my time in
this direction or do i want to go in a
different direction
but let's not get ahead of ourselves
here there was just a small issue with
that prediction that alpha fold had come
in 20th place at casp
we found out that we just computed it
wrong we just done the math wrong at
least you did the math right when it was
important on the actual algorithm we get
the right answer eventually
in actual fact alpha fold came top in
casp that year
it was a strong result but it was still
very far from giving the experimental
methods a run for their money
as well as being painfully slow the
first version of alpha fold achieved
58.9 as its average gdt score
remember you need to be getting over 90
to have a structure that would be
considered true to the real folded
protein
after the casp win deepmind decided to
redouble their efforts
we tried to improve the caste system and
it was giving us some minimal
performance improvements but we were
nowhere close to making the jump that we
wanted
and then there was a breakthrough
alpha fold 2 started by throwing away
everything that had come before
the data fed in was almost entirely
unchanged but the repurposed image
recognition system was gone replaced by
an ai that had been redesigned from the
ground up
just to understand protein folding
[Music]
but how much better was this new and
improved version of alpha fold really
in 2020 the alpha fault team prepared to
enter the next casp competition
keeping a close eye on its score
gdt has gotten better i think we're
making incredibly fast progress and i
think we'll continue to i think it's an
important within our meetings we went
through this tradition where we would
play a song from the year that
corresponded to our gdt and so if we
were at gdt80 we would play a song from
1980 or something like that and
everyone's just like when we get to the
spice girls we know it's okay absolutely
and i don't think we ever did get to the
spice girls either because that would be
97 or so what did you get to
1990 mc hammer something like that
we would have these running sweepstakes
predicting what would be the accuracy of
alpha fold who won the sweepstake i am
not going to tell you who won the
sweepstakes or what was my prediction
but
did you go live at some points i did
follow whether the type of accuracy we
are seeing today was possible
was a completely open question we would
have these meetings with demis and
everyone would think well demis is going
to push our target even higher and they
were not really sure if that was
possible
[Music]
i just felt that all the ingredients
meant there should be a solution to this
and i also believe the original
biologists who said 50 years ago that
this should be possible
in may 2020 the new casp competition
kicked off online nearly a hundred
groups around the world submitted their
predictions for 90 protein targets
once team alpha fold had submitted their
predictions they faced an agonizing wait
for the results to be verified but after
a month or so i got this email from john
malt the founder of casp and it had a
title i think it was zoom request
you're not going to turn down that zoom
are you no and so we dialed in to a
pre-existing team social and john just
said i'm going to read you an email it
is from john malt as i expect you know
your group has performed amazingly well
in casp 14 both relative to other groups
and an absolute model accuracy it didn't
tell us our exact score but it did tell
us the method seemed to be an
outstanding one how did the rest of the
social go
did you get to crack out the champagne
fantastically well yes i was drinking
some bourbon and we were swapping lots
of reminiscences and stories
oh and the final scoring casp
an average of
92.4 across all targets
here's kasp's founder john molt to be
able to fold up single proteins to this
atomic accuracy is a really amazing and
satisfying thing as we originally framed
the problem this is a solution but in
many ways it's just a start after cast
14 we got hundreds and hundreds of
emails from excited biologists wanting
to try out their system and use it for
particular problems
we did pick out a few cases where we
thought alpha fold was really going to
make an impact
one of those early users of alpha fault
was john mcgeehan whose work on plastic
pollution we heard about at the
beginning of this episode
to understand how alpha fold is helping
john and his colleagues
it's important to appreciate that those
plastic eating enzymes that could help
clean up our oceans
are in fact
proteins
they're non-living proteins that break
chemical bonds and you know if you just
had lunch or dinner they'll be working
in your stomach at the moment digesting
all those different carbohydrates into
sugars the enzymes we're interested in
work in the same way but they actually
start breaking down plastics
[Music]
when that group of japanese scientists
discovered an enzyme that could digest
pet plastic
john and his team set about trying to
understand how it worked on a molecular
level
currently we dig up oil and gas and we
distill from those the chemical building
blocks for plastics and we stick those
together in long chains what the enzyme
does is do the opposite of that it comes
along like a big pair of molecular
scissors and cuts those bonds
and then gives you back those building
blocks
we know there is at least one enzyme
that can break down one specific type of
plastic
by looking through the database of
sequenced proteins the scientists found
a bunch of others that look like they
might work in a similar way for other
plastics
but to make any progress they really
needed to see how they are folded and
structured in three dimensions and
understand how they might work to eat
chains of plastic polymers
solving all these structures takes an
awful long time we've got 100 enzymes
sitting there all needing structures and
each structure takes maybe six months
sometimes even a year depending how
tricky it is
100 enzymes
any of which could have gigantic
potential for our planet sat in a queue
waiting for months or years to have
their structure worked out
without knowing what they look like
there is little hope of designing
synthetic versions that could work
better and faster than the one
discovered in japan
and this is where alpha fold comes in
john mcgeehan sent deepmind seven
enzymes of interest
two of which his team had already solved
the structure for
rather spectacularly in a couple of days
they came back and the first thing i did
was to compare the structures that we
already knew to what they'd predicted
and they're almost perfect actually not
only did it get the three-dimensional
fold right it got all the positions of
where all those key atoms are in the
structure correct as well alpha fold is
now in the process of resolving 100
enzymes that we've chosen but it needn't
stop there we could look at thousands of
enzymes and that's incredibly exciting
because this will massively accelerate
the development of enzymes for different
plastic recycling
beyond tackling plastic pollution the
alpha fold team were well aware that
there were other scientists like those
working in drug discovery who would find
this new tool useful
another organization that was an early
beneficiary of alpha fold is the drugs
for neglected diseases initiative an
international non-profit dedicated to
developing new treatments for neglected
tropical diseases
these are a group of preventable
infectious diseases that really affect
1.7 billion people dr monique wasuna is
the dndi's regional director based in
nairobi over the years she has treated
many people suffering from parasitic
diseases but one patient stands out in
her mind from her time as a junior
doctor in kenya this particular middle
aged man had been unwell for many months
and he was just really getting weaker
and weaker so he had about our team that
was extensioned many many miles away and
he took a walk day and night for five
good days
the patient had been infected with leash
moniesis a parasitic disease found
mainly in eastern africa parts of the
americas and the middle east
symptoms start within a couple of weeks
of being bitten by a female sand fly
you start having a fever your guns might
start swelling your liver your spleen
and in the end if you're not treated you
die
the most deadly form visceral
leachmaniasis poses a risk to 600
million people worldwide and causes an
estimated 20 to 40 000 deaths a year
these patients survived but how many
patients like him will die and nobody
knows that they have died of flesh
manages
it is possible to treat leash menialisis
but you need a long painful course of
drugs over 17 days and that can come
with severe side effects
they are toxic
they damage your liver your kidneys
we have to keep the faith because we
haven't gotten the ultimate treatment
typically neglected tropical diseases
don't get on the radar for
pharmaceutical companies because there's
no market incentive for them
charles mobrey leads dndi's drug
discovery effort from geneva the needs
of these patients are huge they deserve
better treatments the way people living
in wealthy countries benefit from the
advances in modern medicine
charles and his colleagues are looking
for monique's ultimate treatment a drug
that can kill leash mania parasites can
be easily administered in the field and
does not cause serious side effects
it's an expensive and time-consuming
process so dndi have had to rely on a
more pragmatic way of finding new drug
treatments for neglected diseases
can we find drug molecules that will
kill a parasite in a test tube that
initial starting point requires that we
screen hundreds of thousands of
molecules to find just one that has some
of the right properties
in short it's a bit of a stab in the
dark
there is also no guarantee that a
molecule that can kill a parasite in a
test tube will work inside a human
so instead in recent decades scientists
have opted for a different approach
rather than testing for drug molecules
that kill a bug we can think about
carefully designing molecules that
interfere very specifically with a
process in that bug
but don't interfere with any related
processes in the human
imagine you'd worked out that there was
one particular protein that was vital to
the parasite
if you knew the three-dimensional
structure of that protein you could
explore how different drug molecules
might disable it
the parasites protein is like an
intricately designed three-dimensional
lock covered in cavities and holes
the drug molecules need to act like a
key filling in the spaces and blocking
the protein from functioning
understanding how best to design that
key
is a lot easier if you can just see
everything on a computer screen rather
than have to infer it from laborious
experiments
you can see where the cavities are and
you could bring a molecule up and you
could see how does it fit into that
cavity
and this is where alpha fold comes in
particularly useful
rather than waiting months or years for
an experimental method to come up with a
protein structure that may or may not be
important in a disease
alpha fold can offer a shortcut
[Music]
here's catherine tanya sawanakan again
so it basically changes the situation
from not using structural information
waiting several years for the
experiments to be finished and now we
have this middle way of well i can get
some actionable structural information
within 10-15 minutes oh wow i mean
that's massive yeah it's a huge saving
in the case of leash moniesis scientists
had already identified a drug molecule
that is effective at killing the
parasite in a test tube
unfortunately they reached a dead end
when it came to adapting this molecule
into a usable drug treatment
so they worked backwards first they
tried to work out what part of the
parasite this drug molecule appeared to
be targeting and in the process they
were able to pinpoint a novel protein
that seems critical to stopping the
leash mania parasite in its tracks
so if that protein is shut down the
parasite can't continue it will die it's
not like other proteins that we've
looked at as targets for leash monasis
so that's exciting
the other exciting thing about this
particular protein is that it looks like
it's not unique to leash mania parasites
similar proteins are found in the
parasites that cause other infectious
diseases
you can see how powerful this quickly
becomes
how the structure of proteins can
potentially open the door to drugs that
are effective for multiple diseases
we could be cutting years off the
timeline this is the power of knowing
about the structure and if using alpha
fold predictions we can get to that
starting point quicker it will help us
pick the right projects and move them
more quickly
the hope is that if alpha fold can do
this for charles it will do the same for
scientists working on all kinds of
important problems around the world
and so in july 2021 deepmind took the
step of publicly releasing the
structures of all 20 000 proteins found
in humans
as well as several other organisms
commonly used in labs around the world
everything from worms and fruit flies to
rats and tuberculosis
in time the team aims to fold and
release all 100 million of the proteins
ever discovered for free
for anyone to use
to accelerate the work of scientists
but before this major release a lot of
careful thinking went into reviewing the
risks of doing so
what if for example alpha folds insights
into protein structure were used by a
bad actor to design a rogue protein say
we carried out a full review of this
because of something we we're concerned
about
sasha brown from the ethics team was
involved in the process of sharing alpha
fold with the world we were trying to
understand will
the release of alpha fold help the
creation of new bio weapons or increase
the potency of current known ones and
the view we got from experts was that
the likelihood of protein folds being
used in this manner was small because
non-specialists face several barriers to
enhancing and synthesizing harmful
proteins and they're more likely to use
readily available materials
in other words if someone is intent on
committing an act of bioterrorism there
are currently much easier ways to do it
than getting to grips with the
biochemistry of protein folding
it wouldn't remove any bottlenecks to
using bioweapons at the level that alpha
fold is currently
while it's hoped that the alpha fold
database release will now accelerate the
work of scientists around the world
there is another important point worthy
of mention here
alpha fold doesn't provide a perfect
dictionary that can translate between
protein sequences and folded shape
it's only offering a prediction
the results of cass put it very well
here's john jumper again of the
predictions we made about two-thirds
were at a quality bar they considered
competitive with experiment so that
means one-third
they're pretty sure that we have
deficiencies although typically small
ones and so it's very important to us
how do we make sure we're doing more
good than harm
there are many reasons why alpha folds
prediction might be uncertain
some proteins have never been seen
before others might have strange
disordered shapes and so on
so the alpha fault team have built in a
way for the model to put a number on its
confidence in its prediction of a given
protein shape
alpha fold predicts the score it would
have got for that protein had it been
part of the original caste competition
here's pushmi kohli to explain
it's very good at that uncertainty
estimation
it's not shy in saying i don't know
which is i think a good thing install
the humility package
essentially when alpha fold solved one
problem it opened up a whole new world
of questions and possibilities for
science
it's very important to note that it does
not solve protein understanding writ
large in terms of making sense of how do
proteins operate so the community has
appreciated the breakthrough that has
been made
but also at the same time there is a lot
more work that needs to be done
in many ways alpha fold is just the
beginning of demonstrating how ai can be
used to advance scientific discovery
and in fact it isn't just proteins that
deepmind is working on researchers are
also successfully applying machine
learning to other areas of science
including genomics chemistry nuclear
fusion mathematics and ecology
in episode 6 of this podcast we'll be
exploring some of those projects in more
detail trust me you won't want to miss
it
but deep mind say they have a bigger
mission of solving intelligence
so i want to end this episode by asking
how alpha fold fits in with that
does alpha fold have any of the
hallmarks of intelligence
i mean what is intelligence oh that's a
whole kind of worms yeah exactly and as
a former worm researcher i know worms
right so this is very much a can of
worms here we're talking about
intelligence in terms of being able to
accomplish a specific task that humans
can't do so it's something that is a
superhuman ability
it is very good at learning from the
existing structures that we have but i
wouldn't call that artificial
intelligence necessarily because that
term generally refers to something that
is more of a generalist whereas i see
elf fold as a specialist
[Music]
i think it's really
important to remember that these are
really powerful techniques that we've
developed that are still far short of a
real artificial intelligence
that you can talk about thinking and
making decisions and everything else
[Music]
if you think our fold isn't intelligent
how does it fit in with that broader
goal of deep mind towards solving
intelligence
this is an example of how we work on
these really hard problems that stretch
us and how do we develop new ideas and
techniques and then think about which of
those will pull
back into the core mission which of
those take us one step closer to general
intelligence
over the next four episodes of this
podcast we'll be taking an in-depth look
at that core mission building artificial
general intelligence or agi
starting with the big push to give
machines the ability to communicate with
humans
me
what's my worst feature model you're
going to get upset if i tell you
[Music]
deepmind the podcast was presented by me
hannah fry
it was written by me and dan hardoon who
is the series producer
if you've enjoyed this episode please
subscribe to the podcast and leave us a
rating or review if you can
bye for now